hey chess friends national master james
kent iii here with chess.com and today
we have game of the day with the white
pieces we have stock fish and with the
black pieces we have layla chess
zero let's get right into it let's see
what we have here and there's d4 from
stockfish and knight f6 knight f3 and g6
so maybe kings indian maybe a grunfeld
something like that then you see g3
which these systems are very very
confusing sometimes especially because
you don't know when they're going to
play c4 are they going to play c4 are
they going to double pin kettle there's
so many things that can happen here in
these positions but the main move that
you usually play here is if you're going
to play g6 you should follow up with
bishop g7 after bishop g7 same thing if
you play g3 you should probably follow
up with bishop g2 very easy and then
here we have d5 right which is actually
some type of grunfeld in a way of course
c4 hasn't been played yet but after
capsules castles and c4 c6 this is now
by transposition into the finchetto
variation of the grunerfield these are
actually the the very nicer lines or of
course so there's a reputation of being
boring from having the c6 lines
especially after these next moves takes
takes we have kind of a dry position
it's symmetrical and it's symmetrical
positions the stuff's really dry and
it's going to take a long time hence
this game actually went
uh 69 moves so a lot of moves to go
through today after 95 there's knight to
e4 this is all theory by the way this
all can happen you also have a knight c6
option option you have a knight to g4
and bishop f5 knight to e4 steel
symmetrical and knight to c3
i can break symmetry right now by
playing knight takes c3
or i can play
bishop f5 it defends the fort knight
which is pretty cool it develops at the
same time opens up rick for the um the
the file for uh the work to go to ca
after bishop f4 really boring
symmetrical
super boring engines engines playing too
says it's zeros right now now of course
as a human here there's a lot of play
left and after this move knight takes c3
it is now not symmetrical anymore so
there's a lot you can do here i can now
bully this pawn or i could play
knight c6 and make it more symmetrical
if knight takes c6 oh wow right now of
course this did not happen i take c6
will be 100 symmetrical you can probably
see this maybe ending in a draw or
something like that not not lots of play
but after queen to b3 makes things very
interesting hitting b7 which is a weak
point write something like rig b8 it
will be an error immediately after uh
stuff like knight takes c6 here bishop
takes ba this is a very scary position
here already now but b7 is hanging you
need to do it do something about it
queen d7 doesn't work
so how do you defend the pawn can you
play b6 well b6 is actually going to be
answered by easily knight takes c6 so it
is black to move what do you do in this
position
here's the move here in fact
we're going to defend it
by not defending it at all e6 wow e6
from leela zero says take it i dare you
stockfish says okay show me what you got
queen takes b7 after knight takes c5
here so now we have a double pawn rather
you take with the pawn or the bishop if
pawn takes you have a very cool move
here very hard to spot as well
especially as a human is g5 right g5 not
only gives you some air for the bishop
to tuck on g6 when the bishop moves we
can now take on e5 with the dynamic
position weak pawn right and there's not
a lot over here in fact let's make a
move like bishop to e3 bishop takes c5
with c3 hanging this is defended by the
queen i can bring the bishop back and
i'm actually holding everything together
pretty nice after queen takes b7 knight
takes and stockfish toes bishop takes e5
after bishop takes e5 captures and
captures now we have the double pawns
here but black is down upon black it's
still down upon but it's doubled and
there's weaknesses here saying yes i'm
down a pawn but eventually i'm going to
get it back and i'm going to have so
much pressure on your position that i'm
going to get it back you'll see that a
lot in like the bengal gambit that's a
very very nice opening very advanced but
it does give up a pawn just to have so
much play and activity of the pieces
even being down upon with the potential
to get it back due to white having so
many weaknesses here four weak pawns now
we maybe just say three because this one
can be defended but there are
technically four weak pawns right now
after d takes e5 queen a5 from leela
just zero attacking c3 and getting the
queen on a very nice honestly diagonal
file like it's just great to be on a5
and then c4
from stockfish but let's say something
like work f to c1 this is more of a
natural move c4 is like wow that's
really hard to find or even consider
rook f2c1 is a very very logical move
depending the pawn why do we use the f
rook because a2 is hanging and if you
want to keep our pawn we're going to use
the af rook rook after c1
rook a to b8 hitting the queen queen e7
and the queen is almost trapped but it's
not trapped like it's totally fine after
queen e7 there's rook after c8
attacking c3 uh and queen can go to d6
reason for this is actually um tying the
rook down so rook takes c3 will not work
at all so rook to b2 but i'm still down
the pawn
we're going to stop it right here and
we're going to get back to the game but
i'm still down a pawn
and there's so much activity for black
right rick takes a2 rook takes e2 rook
takes c3 i can always usually get away
from some of these checks now there is
some type of perpetual if the queen is
um gets does dislodge from a5 so you do
want to be careful
of such a such a thing but with that
being said there's a lot of play here
instead a c4 was played so c4 was to
move a set of rook after c1 going for
some dynamic counter play and you can
also almost it's hard to do but it's
almost considering queen takes a a has a
human here but this is uh
this is uh gonna queen probably queen
takes a a b and rook takes and then
bishop takes and you have two rooks for
the queen and a bishop but this this is
if this pawn wasn't here this would
probably be okay for white
um c4 rook a to b8 queen e7 and d take
c4 so we got our pawn back and now it's
passed wow look at that out of all of
this work we finally have something here
gave a pawn back gave a pawn up got it
back and with interest queen two h4
trying to keep an eye on the pawn and
then instead of actually playing rook f
to c8 it was actually a very cool move
actually let's see if you can find it
here black to move what would you do
all right here we go guys hope you're
ready for this after queen h4
after the queen h4 move
you would think you would just play rook
f to c8
pass pawns must be pushed but in fact
you're actually running right into e4
that was the whole intention of queen h4
because there's no bishop g4 anymore but
now you can play g5 and after takes
there's bishop g6 and this is this is
cool and all but this is not what we
actually wanted so in fact what little
chess shows here was bishop c2 very cool
move getting out of the way putting the
bishop um outside of basically this
whole kind of e4 f4 g4 trap and i don't
have to worry about anything anymore so
queen takes c4 okay cool you get your
pawn back we attack your queen queen d4
and then rook b5 a hitting the pawn now
watch how many threats there's going to
be in a row here f4 rig b4 hit the queen
queen e3 okay cool
rick a4 hit the a2 pawn
work out to c1 cool rook c3 attack the
queen
queen d2 what do you do what would you
do here what would you do here
after queen d2 there's actually queen uh
queen to c5 here
another threat king f1
and for your next threat come on
you got it you can find it
rig d4 another threat queen e1 and then
no more threats
h5 we did a lot of threats in a row to
get to this position right here there's
still about 40 moves left from here a
lot of moves but with that being said we
did get a pretty nice position going on
h5 yes i'm down the pawn one two three
four five six versus one two three four
five pawns right so we have five pawns
versus six pawns but the position is so
much better for black here now the
engines give it zeros but as a human you
can't move anything it says white here
the king can't even go here like this is
just a scary position i'll happily give
you your pawn back if we can just change
this position around says white after h5
queen to f2 maybe putting a little bit
of pressure on d4 a5 it didn't really
matter it's like okay now watch how just
black is gonna just slowly squeeze this
position and we're gonna fast forward uh
eventually here because there's so many
moves that we're just kind of like
shuffling improving the position that of
course so we have to fly through some of
these moves so after a5 king the g1
queen before just getting off with a
nasty little pin also e3 was kind of
annoying here but we still could play uh
rook c4 a3 queen to c4 a lot of
shuffling bishop f1 threatening
obviously here so we back up rook to d8
a4 king g7 and then queenie one so kind
of just a lot of shuffling here watch
these moves there's a check queen f2 we
don't want to trade because trade is
definitely going to have white so queen
of b4
queen back to e1 rig d to c8 and now
watch the shuffle bishop h3 and then h4
was a very nice move here from black
attacking g3 also opening the h file so
h4 and if you take queen takes f4 this
is just really bad you don't want to
take that pawn bishop goes back to g2
rig a to c4
or 8 to c4 bishop a8 what a move
bishop a8 h3 and king f1 and now this is
really a grind really a grind here
you'll see sometimes especially watching
grand masters play or engines they just
shuffle but in a way it's a smart
shuffle sometimes just seeing what you
want what you want to do next and the
hardest thing sometimes in chess is
figuring out how to wait and do nothing
in a very good way so actually from here
after king f1 rook to c8 it hits the
bishop bishop goes back we go back to c5
and said we were on c4 before rook two
a2 it's a move it doesn't really attack
anything but it's just getting off the
back rank white has to make a move queen
to d4 just centralizing the queen maybe
there's something we can do waiting for
white to make some type of mistake now
right now it is minus two but in engine
standards here a lot of times it's
actually like fluctuates as many moves
as they make rook 80 a1
and then a bishop to e4 and after bishop
before d1 queen c4 right going back here
in fact the fatal mistake was actually
rook a2 here is still like minus
0.7 and then actually after rook to c4
or actually after um
yeah here bishop h1 bishop h1 rook here
and rook a2 this is where it really got
bad but the position is already bad if
you just look at this as a human right
flip the board if you like to this is
very bad as a human trying to figure out
what to do here i don't have any play
i'm just shuffling pieces queen b4 rook
a to a1 and bishop e4 now it's time to
trade if queen takes i have decisive
results here rook takes c1 is also a
thing as well rook to d1 stepping out of
the way and queen back to c4 keeping the
threat alive and defending king f2
and then this cool move here from black
let's see if you can find it here
actually this is a very instructive
moment it's time to push forward how do
you do it
here it is black plays this move very
nice g5
and we lie break it up break it up make
some weaknesses now of course you
shouldn't take so of course we don't
take and queen f1 and taking here you
will actually open up some space for for
white we don't actually want this to
happen so after g5 there was g4 close it
down boa constrictor karpov style you
can't move anything so after g4 bishop
takes c4 finally queen takes and rook a2
so at least i feel a little bit looser
says white but i can't do anything still
rook to d5 i'm definitely willing to
trade because my pieces are much better
rick a to a1 again is just miserable for
white rook to d4 and f5 this f5 move was
very very strange here but what i mean
what else do you do maybe just king g1
k1 in fact everything right here is
minus six everything is minus six guys
so it's a really rough position but stop
fish toes at five
okay trying to free up whatever we could
take here you can do rook takes d1 you
can do queen takes e5 you can do
anything you want here e takes f5 was
the choice from lilo chess zero and
after this move e6 is just trying to
open up some lines maybe move the rooks
and try to get to the a file just to do
something because we need to do
something after this e6 move there was
an interesting move here instead of just
capturing which most people would do to
just deal with that get done with it of
course this is an engine rook to b4
which is the best move very strong move
rook to b4 and rook a2 after rook a2
queen takes e6 and this move was about
taking on e6 taking on e6 with the queen
now here the rook is absolutely hanging
the rook is hanging right now this
position is so bad minus eight if you
want to be exact here it's such a bad
position that you know as a human you're
gonna move the rook
but the engine says that stockfish says
that this is so bad that i'm just going
to give up the rook that's just pretty
tough now as a human i'll show you a
human line something like move the rook
right but it doesn't really matter in
fact it goes up -10 it was actually less
if you give it the rook which is insane
right but after rook a to d2 f4 happens
and then of course i'm threatening of
course pawn takes g3 if king 2e1 then
you have f3 and which is which is just
brutal just f3 everything i mean you
can't ever survive this you can't
survive this
and of course if pawn takes f4 then we
have rook takes up f4 which is pretty
simple there you also have um h takes g3
if king to e1 you could play h6 g3 as
well which is another move let me f
takes g3 everything wins everything wins
literally so after king to g1 here
instead of taking the rook this is just
insane leela chess did not even want to
take the rook this is just high level
bite from an engine especially from a
human standpoint this is just a free
rook we're going to take the rook every
time
definitely even in a slow push game but
after f4 it's like wow highlighting the
fact that your position is so bad i
don't even want you rook you can have it
after uh f4 here this queen to e1
shuffling so hey you're not going to
take it hopefully you take it now and
not today pretty easy more pressure f3
pawn takes queen takes a2 what else do
you want here after king 2f1
okay i'll take the rook now thanks for
the uh the generosity queen takes a2
and going to d2 queen city 2 is a really
good move just of course uh trying to
trade right it doesn't matter like
good move yeah right yeah everything's
losing but as a human here of course you
can you can play on this game is
completely over especially after we
trade queens and the rooks are doing
well queen city 2 queen e6 stepping out
of the way now let's just fast forward
to the moves here this one is over so
it's always a matter of style and how
you want to do it here but we're just
going to show you the rest of the game
here this game is completely over great
boa constrictor you can't move anything
i won't even take your brook over there
because my position is so good type of
game after queen e6 queen d a ricky five
right which is shuffling i mean
literally you could take this guys you
could just take this
engine leave the chest like oh it's
faster to go queen of heart queen d3 uh
avoiding the trade
when you are i mean this is insane it's
right it's hilarious actually because
usually you trade when you're up now
when you're down don't even think twice
about it in many cases taking on g3 but
let's have zero says is this the best
way queen f6 take on f4 rook takes f4
king e1
you have rook checks you have everything
rookie 6
opening up the diagonal rig d4 we have
five right c1
queen d5 queen of two
and rig d2 everything is winning
queen f1 queen d3
queen takes f7
is over right this has been over but
okay queen takes up seven king takes
rook check king f6 and this is the rest
of the game king f2 the checkmate ended
like this after rook takes e2
king the g1 and the finale which
checkmate do you want
you just choose one queen b1 was legal
chess zeros uh checkmate there but this
was pretty cool pretty uh dynamic game
to say the least especially out of
something that was so boring like a neil
grunfeld that was actually uh
symmetrical in the finchetto variation
pretty cool stuff from lulacha zero
showed us the bold constrictor style
taking your page out of car parks book
bear pretty cool guys i hope you enjoyed
this game i'm national master james
canty third here with
and i'll see you guys on the next video
[Music]
you